la compañía de mira le paga 50 pesos por
hora por trabajar como investigadora y
40 pesos por hora por trabajar como
ingeniera quiere ganar al menos m pesos
esta semana hay menos m pesos esta
semana esto define una restricción en el
número de horas que miran trabaja como
investigadora r horas y como ingeniera y
horas
la restricción esta gráfica da a
continuación y en un segundo vamos a ver
esta gráfica de acuerdo con la gráfica
puedes la cantidad mínima de dinero que
mira quiere ganar esta semana la
cantidad mínima
en otras palabras cuánto es m y bueno
para eso vamos a trabajar justo con
nuestra gráfica que tenemos acá abajo
así que si bajamos la pantalla para ver
esta gráfica que tenemos aquí y para eso
déjeme bajar un poco más la pantalla lo
que quiero que veas es que este eje
representa el número de horas que mira
trabaja como ingeniera este eje
horizontal representa el número
horas horas que mira trabaja como en
general horas como ingeniera
muy bien y este otro eje mi eje vertical
r representa la cantidad de horas el
número de horas que miraba a trabajar o
las que miraba a trabajar como como
investigadora
ves y ya dora muy bien y ya que tenemos
estos dos ejes quiero que te des cuenta
que también sabemos cuál es el pago
total que recibe mira no es así si nos
fijamos primero en el pago total que
ella recibe trabajando como
investigadora bueno pues eso va a
depender de lo cual era el número de
horas que trabaja en ello así que r lo
voy a poner aquí y por cada hora que
ella trabaja como investigadora va a
obtener 50 pesos por lo tanto voy a
poner aquí 50 así que el total de pago
que recibe como investigadora es de 50 r
y si ella trabaja como ingeniera observa
que ya va a trabajar en horas como
ingeniera y horas como ingeniera y ella
va a recibir 40 pesos por cada hora que
trabaje como ingeniera por lo tanto el
pago total que recibe como ingeniera es
de 40
y si nos queremos fijar en el pago total
que ella recibe en la semana bueno pues
va a ser la suma de estos 25
r 40m este es el pago que ella recibe
como investigadora y este es el pago que
ella recibe como ingeniera y en esta
área su la da en toda esta área que
tenemos aquí podemos ver todas las
posibles combinaciones del número de
horas que ella trabaja como ingeniera y
del número de horas que ella trabaja
como investigadora así que por ejemplo
si nos tomamos este punto de aquí bueno
este punto de aquí representa el
escenario en donde ella trabaja 50 horas
como investigadora 50 horas como
investigadora y cinco horas como
ingeniera cinco horas como ingeniera
bueno estaría bastante bien aunque aquí
no tendría el pago mínimo que estamos
buscando cierto entonces como podré
obtener ese pago mínimo entonces como
puede obtener el pago mínimo bueno el
pago mínimo en la semana son todos los
puntos de esta recta de color azul que
vemos aquí
a estos puntos y nota las soluciones de
todos los puntos que satisfacen la
desigualdad están arriba de esta recta
así que en la recta obtendríamos el pago
mínimo y cuando estamos en la recta por
ejemplo aquí en este punto de aquí en
donde tenemos un cero
es decir cero horas como ingeniera voy a
poner aquí sus coordenadas tengo 0,40 r
es decir 40 horas como investigadora en
este punto de aquí es un punto en donde
se minimiza el pago así que cuando mira
trabaja 40 horas como investigadora es
decir si vale 40 déjame ponerlo aquí si
me vale 40 y en en este caso vale 0
vale 0 entonces en este caso cuánto
dinero va a recibir de pago bueno pues
sustituyendo en esta ecuación de arriba
tendríamos 50 por 40 50 por 40 es 2000
más 40 por 0 y esto se va entonces me
quedaría dos mil dos mil pesos
es decir que este punto de aquí
corresponde a dos mil pesos
en este punto de equip corresponden a
dos mil dos mil pesos
y puedes ver que cualquiera de estos
puntos que tenemos en la recta azul
cualquiera de ellos corresponde a 2000
pesos por ejemplo este otro aquí este
otro de aquí bueno corresponde cuando
vale 50 y r vale 0 estás de acuerdo en
este punto de aquí déjame escribirlo en
este caso r va a valer cero eleva vale
cero y va a valer 50 y va a valer 50 y
bueno si hacemos las cuentas
correspondientes observa que vamos a
llegar al mismo escenario 50 x 0 esto se
va a más 40 por 50 lo cual también son
dos mil pesos
esos dos mil pesos una vez más llegamos
al mismo resultado así que lo mismo que
ella puede ganar son dos mil pesos eso
quiere decir que sin regresamos al
problema original am emen m va a valer
dos mil pesos m es la cantidad mínima de
dinero que mira pueda ganar en la semana
y es dos mil pesos dos mil pesos y de
hecho podemos expresar esta desigualdad
que tenemos aquí de la siguiente manera
50 ere 40 tiene que ser mayor o igual
que 2000 que 2000 perfecto y además nos
preguntan otra cosa recuerda nos
preguntan pueden ir a cumplir con su
restricción trabajando durante 25 horas
como ingeniera y durante 10 horas como
investigadora 25 horas como ingeniera y
10 como investigadora bueno pues veamos
que me dice mi gráfica de aquí
tengo 25 horas como ingeniera 25 horas
como ingeniera y 10 como investigadora
estaríamos en este punto de aquí así que
no estamos en un punto donde ella puede
alcanzar el mínimo deseado ella no
obtiene ni siquiera sus dos mil pesos
mínimos y entonces en este punto no
estamos en nuestro conjunto solución así
que si nos preguntan y dejamos subir la
pantalla para ver qué me preguntaban
dice esto define una restricción en el
número de horas que mira trabaja como
investigadora r y como ingeniera en la
restricción esta gráfica a continuación
pueden ir a cumplir con su restricción
trabajando durante 25 horas como
ingeniera y durante 10 horas como
investigadora no
en definitiva no